Welcome back everyone this would be my new
spider-man no way home video for the big thor
4 love and thunder easter egg that everybody's
been talking about recently so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there's so many easter eggs in
this movie you could watch it like 10 times
and still find new stuff on the 10th rewatch
careful for spoilers for the movie if you have not
seen it yet because we'll be talking about some
very specific details from the film but during
the early part of the movie when they're doing
the jay jonah jameson daily bugle news broadcast
scenes about spider-man while he's busy yelling
about spider-man there's a news chiron that
runs underneath his video feed with easter
eggs and references for things currently
happening in other parts of earth in the mcu
one of them is a news item referencing things that
are happening in new asgard during the events of
spider-man no way home i will explain the timeline
of the movie and where that picks up too but the
easter egg is meant to set up plot for thor for
love and thunder because after doctor strange
multiverse of madness that is the next mcu movie
that's coming out things just got out of hand
the news chiron just reads that there's currently
political strife in new asgard and there's this
large z symbol so a lot of people believe that
this is meant to be a reference to russell crowe's
zeus character in the current political situation
with thor leaving new asgard to travel with the
guardians of the galaxy after avengers end game
and naming valkyrie the new king of asgard so
quick timeline explainer the news chiron happens
early in the movie before the big christmas time
jump at the end so it's around november 2024 when
they're breaking this news meaning the events of
thor 4 will mostly take place within a couple
months probably of the end of spider-man no way
home not that long after the ending scene where
he's swinging through rockefeller center in the
new comic book accurate cloth spider-man suit with
a new spider-man symbol so it just sounds like
while this is happening with spider-man while jay
jonah jameson is going crazy spider-man is busy
breaking the multiverse with dr strange's spell
with doctor strange's help no less while all
that's going down there's a bunch of problems
in new asgard with valkyrie being the new king
and it's been about a year and a half since the
end of avengers end game so technically she's been
king for about a year and a half now and it
probably has something to do with thor naming
her king in people in new asgard other characters
from the nine realms that have ties to new asgard
having a problem with valkyrie being the new king
so but people need a king no they already have one
that's funny even though there's a lot of
questions as to her actual title like thor
implied he was giving her the title of king of new
asgard even though she's a woman so technically
she'd be queen of asgard in its sole ruler not
the king of asgard like in the comics when odin
is severely disabled or he stops being king for
brief periods of time his wife frigga or freya
just depending on the comics that you're reading
takes over leadership she becomes a sole ruler
but she's queen of asgard when odin stops being
king briefly she does not become king of asgard
like in real life queen elizabeth and prince
philip queen elizabeth is the sole monarch like
she has the sole authority but you don't call
her king elizabeth i believe the thor 4 movie
will have a way of explaining why valkyrie or
thor calls her king of asgard but early theory
you have a lot of other powerful thor related
characters from the nine realms that they do in
the thor movies from the thor comics that probably
contest her leadership of new asgard like they all
probably feel like they have claims to the throne
as well typically a god has ruled over asgard so
there are probably a lot of other lesser gods
who also want to claim the throne making more
black panther references there was also a battle
for the throne like at the beginning of the movie
umbaku challenged t'challa for the throne you have
killmonger who came along later in the movie and
challenged t'challa for the throne successfully
so it just sounds like there's another situation
like that happening in new asgard during the
events of spider-man no way home that'll sort
of set the stage for what's happening during thor
4. if you have all the extra social and cultural
aspects of being a monarch like do you have a
family do you have heirs in case you die like who
would take the throne after valkyrie if something
happened to her and like i said we do have gore
the god butcher in thor 4 coming to new asgard
as he goes around the universe on his quest to
kill all the gods of the mcu so the reason that
russell crowe's zeus character might be at new
asgard is just to assert a claim to the throne or
he might not like valkyrie and might try to take
the throne from her briefly or just assert himself
as a better candidate for ruler in thor's absence
since there are a lot of parallels you could draw
between odin and zeus he is another one of the
major marvel sky fathers there are greek gods in
the mcu they're all canonical like that's where
hercules comes from for those of you that want
to see hercules in avengers movie like avengers 5
and most of you will remember that ares was
featured on the grand masters tower as one of the
previous winners of the contest of champions so
a version of aries already exists inside the mcu
zeus is physically stronger than odin
but the odin force makes odin vastly
more powerful than zeus so in a regular fight
odin would always win but zeus would normally
be way more powerful than someone like valkyrie
who was just a normal member of the valkyries
you're a valkyrie i thought the valkyrie had all
died gruesome death they're just a hardcore elite
asgardian fighting force made up of the female
warriors like they're the asgardian's version
of the dora melange if you're wondering what
happened to the valkyries they get into that
during thor ragnarok there's this big flashback
scene where you see all of them killed by hela
when they try to imprison her except for tessa
thompson's valkyrie so valkyrie doesn't have god
tier powers like thor odin or hela or even zeus
and since russell crowe's only doing a small cameo
scene as zeus in the movie early theory here gore
the godbutcher probably kills him when he comes
to new asgard looking for odyn thor loki any other
gods that he can find mostly he would come looking
for someone like odin or thor though like they're
the famous ones across the universe that everybody
knows about no matter where you live in valkyrie
doesn't even call herself a god nobody thinks of
her as a god so gore wouldn't be coming to kill
her loki died during avengers infinity war or
at least the main version of loki tom hiddleston
also claimed he wasn't going to be in the movie
as any version of loki but marvel actors lie
about a lot of stuff like that all the time
there's been a report that he's going to show up
during doctor strange multiverse of madness so
our new version of loki will show up in the movies
they do have matt damon's loki in the movie along
with luke hemsworth's fake thor and they have a
fake version of hela played by melissa mccarthy
because we're going to do another one of those
funny fake plays but this time it'll be about
the events of thor ragnarok to sort of recap the
events of the previous movie because it's been
a couple years and also set up the reveal for how
jane foster gets mjolnir even though that doesn't
really have anything to do with spider-man no
way home i've already done a video about the
version of mjolnir that jane foster's going to
wield based on footage from the movie it just
looks like the way they explain the twist in the
film is that odin's enchantment plus the magic
that was already in mjolnir itself will just be
enough to reform the broken pieces of the original
mjolnir when something happens in new asgard and
it deems jane foster worthy probably something
to do with gore the god butcher showing up and
slaughtering a bunch of asgardians we've already
seen a lot of footage of thor and the guardians
of the galaxy coming to new asgard during the
film but it's not clear at what point in the film
that's going to happen i'm assuming because of the
way they did the fake play during thor ragnarok
thor will also be around for the new version of
the fake play with the fake version of hela and
he'll also be around to watch jane foster become
the female version of thor when mjolnir reforms
itself if it wasn't clear new asgard basically
used to be the tonsberg norway village that you
see in all the thor flashbacks in the first movie
you also see it during the first captain america
movie that's where odin hid the tesseract
it just implied that odin was really fond of this
new townsburg village and just kept coming back
here over the centuries this little shrine that
they built here with all these special structures
is literally the site where odin died they've
kind of enshrined it as a special sacred place
and this little pyre here that you see this little
monument is also the place where mjolnir's broken
pieces lay after hela broke it like they didn't
pick up all the pieces of mjolnir and then put it
into storage they just put them all on a special
pedestal here and built something around it
but because the next big marvel movie is actually
going to be doctor strange multiverse of madness
i'm guessing that movie will also probably take
place either right before thor love and thunder if
it's not right around the same time because a lot
of times the marvel producers will say oh you know
what's happening around the same time as these
other movies that are coming out right next to it
with very few exceptions the mcu movies happen
in a linear way like so the timeline sort of
moves along so one movie happens just a little
while after the events of the previous movie
so when doctor strange and all of his variants
in scarlet witch like doctor strange supreme and
defender strange try to fix whatever's happening
with the multiverse all of reality from collapsing
right as they're dealing with that the events
of thor love and thunder probably pick up
and they did confirm that the guardians would
be a significant part of the movie but i believe
they're only around for the early part i'm not
expecting them to be like a huge part through
the entire events of the film if you guys didn't
realize too next year around this time around the
christmas holiday they're actually going to have a
guardians of the galaxy holiday special it's going
to be a bit of a parody on the star wars holiday
special but it will be live action and it will
set up the events of guardians of the galaxy 3. so
it'll take place after the events of whatever the
guardians are doing during thor love and thunder
they'll probably release a trailer for that when
thor love and thunder comes out in theaters next
summer but if you have any questions about what's
going on during thor love and thunder or the
easter eggs and spider-man no way home just
write them below in the comments there's another
brand new spider-man no way home deleted scenes
video that i'll be posting later this week a bunch
more deleted scenes and alternate endings that we
learned about because the movie changed a lot
while they were making it in big reminder the
star wars book of boba fett series is starting my
episode 1 video we'll post next it's the star wars
mandalorian spin-off it's like the mandalorian
season 2.5 with a bunch of those characters like
grogu and mando crossing over so make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss that everyone click here to learn about the
spider-man no way home alternate ending and all
those deleted scenes and click here for my full
doctor strange multiverse of badness trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!